[Music]
what's so great about the Great Lakes
they're known as America's inland seas
the North American Great Lakes Huron
Ontario Michigan Erie and superior are
so massive that they border eight states
and contain 23 quadrillion litres of
water that's enough to cover the land
area of the contiguous United States
three meters deep these vast bodies of
water spanned forests grassland and
wetland habitats supporting a region
that's home to over 3,500 species but
how did such a vast and unique
geological feature come to be the story
begins near the end of the last ice age
over ten thousand years ago a time when
the climate was warming and the glaciers
that cloaked the Earth's surface began
their slow retrieved these immense ice
sheets carved out a series of basins
those basins filled with water as the
ice began to melt creating the world's
largest area of freshwater lakes over
time channels developed between these
basins and water began to flow in an
ongoing exchange that persists to this
day in fact today the interconnected
Great Lakes contain almost 20% of the
world's supply of fresh surface water
the waters journey begins in the far
north of Lake Superior which is the
deepest coldest and clearest of the
lakes containing half the system's water
Lake Superior sinks to depths of 406
metres creating a unique and diverse
ecosystem that includes more than 80
fish species a given drop of water
spends on average 200 years in this lake
before flowing into Lake Michigan or
Lake Huron linked by the straits of
mackinac these two lakes are technically
one to the west lies Lake Michigan the
third largest of the lakes by surface
area water slowly moves through its
cul-de-sac shape and encounters the
world's largest freshwater dunes many
wildlife species and unique fossilized
coral to the east is Lake Huron which
has the longest shoreline it's sparsely
populated but heavily forested
including seven thousand year old
petrified trees below them water
continues to flow south eastwards from
Lake Huron into Lake Erie this lake
status as the warmest and shallowest of
the five has ensured an abundance of
animal life including millions of
migrating birds finally the water
reaches its last stop by dramatically
plunging more than 50 meters down the
thundering Niagara Falls into Lake
Ontario the smallest lake by surface
area from there some of this
well-traveled water enters the st.
Lawrence River eventually reaching the
Atlantic Ocean in addition to being a
natural wonder the perpetually flowing
Great Lakes bring us multiple benefits
they provide natural water filtration
flood control and nutrient cycling by
moving water across more than 3200
kilometers the Great Lakes also provide
drinking water for upward of 40 million
people and 212 billion liters a day for
the industries and farms that line their
banks but our dependence on the system
is having a range of negative impacts to
the Great Lakes coastal habitats are
being degraded and increasingly
populated exposing the once pristine
waters to industrial urban and
agricultural pollutants because less
than 1% of the water leaves the lake
system annually decades-old pollutants
still lurk in its waters humans have
also inadvertently introduced more than
100 non-native and invasive species into
the lakes such as zebra and quagga
mussels and sea lampreys that have
decimated some indigenous fish
populations on a larger scale climate
change is causing the waters too warm
thus reducing water levels and changing
the distribution of aquatic life luckily
in recent years governments have started
to recognize the immense value of this
natural resource partnerships between
the United States and Canada are
underway to reduce pollution protect
coastal habitats and halt the spread of
invasive species protecting something as
massive as the Great Lakes system will
require the collaboration of many
organizations but the effort is critical
if we can preserve the wonder of this
flowing Inland Sea
Oh
[Music]
you